what's up modern stuts we're here at the
Mother Earth News fair and we're looking
at some nice gardening tools that this
gentleman makes in his backyard let's
find out how he does it so what's your
process of making your of all these nice
fine tools well it obviously it varies a
little bit from tool to Tool but first
step is the forging uh we start forging
all the shanks first uh the blades I cut
these blades out in a plasma machine we
buy this in 4x8 sheets uh
and depending like I say depending on
the tool and quite what we're doing
we'll do all the forging get ready to
weld and then there's a cleanup step to
get this uh down to pristine metal for
the weld weld them on there and then the
TRS for example they go back they go for
another round of forging where I cup
them and put the bend in them after that
they sit and cool off a little bit to
where we can mess with them again and
then they go back into the forge a third
time for a heat treat cycle that's the
uh you can see the heat treat line here
where we've got a hard Edge out here
that Fades back to softer more ductal
material in the center y uh from the way
the slag holds on to it there so what's
the best way to condition this after
you've been using them for a while uh
well after you've used them for a while
a little bit of any kind of a light oil
uh I like the beeswax and linseed oil
because the wax gives the oil a little
bit of extra tack to to help hold on um
the reality is like these are dipped in
beeswax and linseed oil now
but uh they're all carbon steel over
time they're going to pick up rust and
the best way to maintain your tools is
just keep using them awesome if it rusts
uh you're not using enough go yeah
you're not using it enough and once you
start using it again it's going to be
shiny again in a couple hours now the
handles way just f with beeswax or
tongue oil or tongue oil linseed oil
little beeswax just the natural oil off
your hand if you're using it a lot
that's where you really want to take
your time to take care of it is the
handle itself don't leave them out where
they're getting wet dry wet dry um take
good care of the handle and the rest of
it will be fine you yeah a little bit of
rust on this isn't going to hurt it
within the first couple hours of using
it again it'll be shined up and and look
like a new one again these tools are
awesome guys I'm going to leave a link
down in the description below hope you
guys enjoyed that video don't forget to
go check out will over at the homestead
iron the link will be down in the
description below and tell them hi from
lumni Acres we'll see you guys next time
[Music]